and let us get ready for rescue let's
get ready for rescue this is a sound
coming through the tunnel on board one
of Europe's largest migrant rescue ships
as they spot an abandoned and
overcrowded fishing boat carrying
hundreds of people it's a tale that has
become far too familiar of desperation
near death and the politics of migration
as people flee conflict poverty and
persecution in search of what they
believe will be the safety of Europe's
Shores
I'm Liz Bates and on this episode of Sky
News Daily we'll hear a harrowing
account from the front line of one of
the most dangerous routes North Africa
across the Mediterranean
foreign
already this year at least a thousand
migrants have died trying to cross and
as summer approaches it's getting busier
but first Sky News Europe correspondent
Adam Parsons has been witnessing it all
up close he joined one of the rescue
organizations on board the geoberants an
80 meter long rescue ship on the lookout
for migrant vessels in distress he's
still on board the ship now docked in
Italy and tells us about the moment that
they found one it was a quite incredible
sight you could see people gripping on
to to every window frame uh every inch
field I mean just imagine this boat is
probably capable of 30 or 40 people it's
got over 600 on it to put that into
context that is a decent sized Village
of people crammed into this this one
boat I and you can see you can Glimpse
all sorts of details I remember seeing a
guy wearing a leather jacket and even
within this cacophony of sound and these
smells and all these this nervous
tension I remember thinking why on Earth
would you make this journey through this
beating sun and still keep worrying your
leather jacket people with these
rucksacks and they would jump into the
boat and with their rucksack and and
cling to it for dear life and and you
know small children they're sort of
babies and uh these children who seemed
so so vulnerable and you can Glimpse all
of this from the side but of course at
the same time you are trying for there
you're trying to offer assistance to
people who are in you know in desperate
need and I think the other thing that
your senses take in is is that sort of
sense of the salt from the sea the wind
the the sort of is coming against you
and the sheer fact that here we are you
can't see anything else when in the
middle of the sea there's no land to be
seen no other ships except the Italian
Coast Guard the two rescue boats this
Hulk of a fishing vessel and then the
Geo Barons the the huge rescue ship uh
in the background and other than that
there is nothing to be seen until the
Horizon in every direction you'd imagine
there'd be a sense of Jubilation but
there kind of was from some people lots
of waving and other people just totally
silent really still
and I I think some of that was because
they were so ill and some of it was
because they just didn't know what was
going on and I've subsequently told us
they thought we might have been pirates
they didn't know who we might have been
kidnapping them so a real range of
emotions from me I must say it was just
a sense of wow those really are hundreds
and hundreds of people how on Earth are
we going to get all of these people off
this boat safely and the conditions on
the boat well I I mean imagine so the
testimony of of other people is really
Grim
um they've been at sea for about four
days the water had run out the food was
very sparse that they had left and what
they had left was rotting uh they one
guy said to me that they'd had one slice
of bread one day but then other day they
had a round of cheese designed for for
eight people he said they'd had a big
thing of water at finished in the end
people were just taking tiny sips and
then we know that without water people
really really struggle to stay alive and
various people have talked about this
you start having this fantasy of
drinking seawater even though you know
that that you can't do it we made
repeated Journeys and every time we came
back we thought well just the number
isn't going down and that's because what
we couldn't see when we first got there
was an underbelly you know people right
in the bottom of the boat there were
hundreds of them and I spoke to some of
the survivors and they they sat and
clenched their legs together and said
This Is How They survived spent days
effectively barely able to move hunched
up in the bottom uh of the boats I mean
clearly no no sanitary facilities on
this at all a really really Grim picture
and that is why
and I believe them when they say this
they thought they were going to die that
they by the time we found them Captain
had abandoned the ship no one knew how
to uh how to work it they didn't know
which direction to go they had no Maps
no navigation running out of food had no
water a lot of them I think it'd
reconcile themselves to the fact that
that they were going to die okay and
give us a sense of like who these people
are where are they from is it a mixture
of uh men and women so what we now know
is that there were 606 people on board a
boat that I I think probably could
safely accommodate 30 uh or 40. the boat
had left the Libyan Port of to Brook it
would seem a majority of them are
Egyptians there are plenty of other
nationalities under the bangladeshis uh
pakistanis syrians on board I'm sure
plenty of other nationalities as well
libyans you would imagine
um and and they've come from a variety
of background variety of Ages from a
three-month-old baby who I saw the
youngest Survivor up to uh up to people
who are I guess well into their 60s
most of them uh are adult men uh not
that many women although there was a
pregnant woman on board but actually a
very high number over a hundred miners
are you find it as anyone under 18 and
that again goes from three months old to
to 18 year olds so lots of children lots
of men not many women
what gets them onto those boats the
expectation I think among some of them
is that they might die when they board
those boats why do they get on well I
don't think that that expectation is
there when they board the boats I I
think the truth is we have a lot more
information
about this than they do so when I told
one of these migrants that actually this
is the most dangerous migration route in
the world he had absolutely no idea I
told him a thousand people have died in
this Central Mediterranean route this
year it was it was shocked uh of course
in retrospect it doesn't seem that
shocking because he pretty nearly added
to that statistic but but he said he was
told that he he had paid money and
thought he was going to get a calm
crossing the person who took his money
said you will barely notice even the
waves on this boat you know it had been
pitched almost like a guaranteed gentle
cruise to take you to Europe and and
that of course is is what's driving them
is determination desperation and
economics so so nobody wants to make
this journey you know nobody jumps onto
one of these boats uh willingly and I
suspect if they had known how Grim it
was they might really have thought twice
about it but I think very often these
are people who think that their lives
are desperately bad and that their
circumstances are grim and that their
duty is to provide for their families
which they cannot do and that's why
they're getting on these boats and
heading to Europe because they think it
offers the promise of a much much better
future so medicine some Frontier who is
the charity that oversaw this rescue
operation no question that the work that
they've been doing is awe-inspiring but
there has been some criticism that they
are creating a kind of infrastructure or
safety net almost that is acting as
encouragement for people to try to make
this journey do you think that's fair
there's there's absolutely criticism of
medicine yeah and and the other
Charities who provide these rescue boats
uh in the Mediterranean
um I I think as a comparison the the UK
government talks about stopping small
boats the Italian government looks at
big boats like this one like the Geo
Barons and says that they encourage my
migration now the Italian government
maintains that this is their this is
their perspective this is this is their
analysis and they have introduced new
regulations
that do make things more complicated so
for instance every time this boat
carries out a rescue like this it has to
report it to the authorities and then
return back to what's called a port of
safety so in the past they might do
multiple rescues and then bring all of
those people back
but if you take for instance this boat
the last time it went out it rescued
only 26 people and then had to make a
long journey back to Italy to drop them
off I don't think there's any doubt that
that's been done in order to try to to
stymie and interrupt their work
um as I speak to you now but I'm on
board they're disembarking people and
there are three police vans uh here
um as well as other Emergency Services I
think that's partly a symbolic scientist
so we're watching you
um and we don't really approve of you I
think it was one of the Italian
politicians described these uh as the
taxis of the Seas if you ask the charity
themselves
they obviously completely deny this they
say that the vast majority of rescues
are actually done by the Italian Coast
Guard
and that foreign they say they're
responding to a problem that they're not
creating it but it's definitely
something that plays very potently in in
Italy and probably in the wider world
you're covering this as a journalist
how how difficult is it to see it from
the angle of just a human being what's
it like for you to do you ever think of
your own family I've covered migration
from for a long time whether it's in
land producer or Lesbos or or many many
days but in northern France
um and always it comes down to human
stories what was different here was was
seeing it so close up and it's a
visceral
it was a visceral time because it was it
was the sound of the sea it was the
sound of people screaming whether it was
a baby it was the kind of the smell of
the soul that we were on these rubber
boats and as they heated up under the
sun you could smell that that plastic
and and the emotion you could smell the
boat not to put too fine a point on it
it was the speed at which we went across
the water but of course more than
anything it was the people it's the sort
of pleading hands uh people acting as a
team throwing life jackets on and and
then being passed around the boat rather
than being sort of kept and corralled in
in one area it's uh on I think a second
boatload a man got on what an older man
who was wearing a big overcoat and he
grabbed me and kissed me on the cheek
and he had stubble and I sort of can
still feel that as I say it I was a
woman who got on
and she looked really pale and uh and I
was hoping to sit down and she just fell
dead weight right on top of me nearly
knocked both of us over the side uh and
and but there's nothing you can do you
you put her down and I asked the woman
who I I sat next word you'd hold her
hand and just sort of look after her and
keep and then there was a Doctrine board
uh who'd seen obviously so much more of
this and he looked at him and said look
she'll be fine until she gets to the to
the Geo balance and someone can examine
it so everyone you looked at had a story
you know all of these people are humans
and
and whatever your politics whatever your
view of migration I don't think you can
ever take the humanity out of it whether
you see these people as Asylum Seekers
or economic migrants nobody wanted to be
on that boat nobody wanted to risk death
in the middle of the Mediterranean so so
yeah I think you do think of of that
that human side and how it plays into
the the political and all the other
dimensions that make migrations as a
complex issue give us a sense of what
happens to these people now where are
you what is the next stage of their
Journey what will they be facing so we
just docked in uh in the Italian port of
Bari initially they go through a kind of
Red Cross facility where they're given
flip-flops pair of shoes they're checked
over for the for the health some of them
are put in hazmat suits I guess if
there's a there's a fear over their
health and as I look now I can say cue
long huge snaking off to my left towards
a blue building my understanding is that
inside that building yeah they're
getting that kind of initial processing
of who they are where they've come from
do they have a passport do they have any
family in Europe and fingerprints will
be taken so this is effectively the
first stage of processing then in the
first stage of fulfilling that ambition
that so many of these people have which
is to start a new life in Europe
let's now speak to Ali Fortescue she's
our political correspondent so you have
become I think our resident immigration
expert
um because it's such a an important
issue in UK politics but today we're
talking about it across Europe and in
particular Italy there is always the the
human tragedy at the center of it but
the Politics as well at the moment it
seems like it's never far away can you
give us a sense of How It's shaped
Italian politics over recent years yeah
I think you know Italy is obviously
a it's a country where immigration has
always been a Hot Topic because of its
geography you know Italy and Greece are
so close to North Africa that
traditionally they've shouldered a lot
of the burden
um from immigration and
um that's why we've seen kind of
right-wing populist parties rising and
of course now Georgia Maloney from a
right-wing party Brothers of Italy is
now in charge in Italy and
this is becoming increasingly important
because this year there are reported
predictions that we could see half a
million people entering Italy from North
Africa obviously with all the knock-on
effects that has for the rest of Europe
and that is going to be a challenge for
Georgia Maloney who has put immigration
at the center of her pitch and it's her
first full year in charge and more
widely across Europe are we seeing it
affect politics and filter through in
different ways yeah I think so look I
think
2015 was obviously a bit of a turning
point that's the moment that kind of we
saw hundreds of thousands of people
heading for Europe in part because of
wars in Syria Iraq Afghanistan and it's
an issue that has long divided you I
mean you'll remember Merkel a welcoming
people with open arms in Germany in
Hungary completely different approach
they broke EU law on protecting
vulnerable immigrants
um so it's an issue that is kind of
divided Europe and yeah we have seen
since 2015 the rise of right-wing
populist parties we've seen right-wing
governments elected in Hungary in Poland
in Austria in Italy of course a threat
from Marine Le Pen in France and that is
all something that is in part in large
part driven by immigration
you traveled recently to the Council of
Europe in Iceland with Rishi sunak now
they were telling us beforehand that
migration was going to be top of the
agenda
um at that was it discussed and how much
agreement was there I think I think
interesting because
it was definitely Rishi sunak was
definitely the person that wanted to
talk about that more than anyone else
and at the start of the Council of
Europe which really like you know the
focus more broadly was on Ukraine
the leaders of each country were
standing up most of them talking only
about Ukraine and Rishi soon actually
started talking about stopping the bows
so I think that gives you a sense you
know in British domestic politics how
important this is for him certainly the
rhetoric he also wanted to talk about um
the European convention on human rights
which is quite kind of specific problem
here with the Rwanda flights and we know
that the European judges that stopped
that flight from departing
um but a lot of it feels like you know
they're talking about communicating
about better cooperation a lot of it
felt to me like rhetoric that we've kind
of heard before and obviously you have
Robert generate the immigration Minister
this week in North Africa and in Europe
talking again about Corporation whether
or not that will actually you know make
a difference I think remains to be seen
yeah and of course all made slightly
more difficult uh post-brexit when it
comes to cooperation
um
as Richardson like I said and many
European leaders are said and we see
we're seeing this in Italy it was with
um George Maloney they say they are
intent on stopping
legal migration across the sea onto
European Shores what is preventing
European leaders from really making
progress on that well I think firstly
it's difficult like we know that
disrupting these smuggling gangs is
never going to be easy when you have
people that are desperate to come into
Europe and willing to pay time you know
sometimes thousands of pounds and
Smugglers willing to help them and
willing to find you know new routes be
that geographically or new routes for
example now I've seen people coming on
boats not in lorries anymore as long as
it's an incredibly lucrative business at
the center of it it's such a lucrative
business and I think disrupting that is
very difficult we know that the National
Crime agency in this country have been
working in Europe they say that there's
like there's no easy fix this is so
difficult we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of people being displaced
and of course you know different people
have different countries have different
views as I've said already
um and I guess you also need the
political will for countries to actually
work together for example you know
Britain and France they need to work
together but actually is it perhaps in
France interest for boats to cross the
channel won't come to Britain because
that means people are leaving France and
that feeds into their kind of
immigration policy so I guess you know
the political will and the difficulty
the problem mean and the fact that we're
seeing more and more people
fleeing persecutions being depleted
displaced makes it really difficult
my thanks to Adam Parsons Ali Fortescue
and to you for listening to this episode
of The Sky News Daily it was produced by
Emma Ray Woodhouse the editor was Philly
Beaumont